es
una activista por el medio ambiente se
toma el micrófono y denuncia que la cob
26 es un fracaso después de que los
países acordaran a reducir en lugar de
eliminar el carbón este cambio de última
hora promovido por india y china provocó
la frustración de muchos delegados sobre
todo los de las naciones insulares de
este compromiso sobre el carbón era el
punto brillante del acuerdo era uno de
los puntos que esperábamos sacar de aquí
para volver a casa con orgullo y nos
duele mucho ver que ese bulto ha sido
atenuado aceptamos este cambio con la
mayor reticencia edad bites fighting
activistas como greta tandberg y ongs
han también expresado su descontento
y
creo que es un acuerdo débil pero envía
una señal para el fin del carbón así que
es algo bueno pero no llega el momento
apenas mantiene a la vista el objetivo
de los 15 grados
[Música]
sin embargo algunos como el primer
ministro británico boris johnson ven
este acuerdo final como una victoria y
subrayan que es la primera vez que se
menciona claramente el carbón en
documentos de este tipo de la onu arcos
todavía queda un largo largo camino por
recorrer antes que podamos decir que
hemos lidiado con el cambio climático
pero la gran noticia es que el mundo ha
logrado algunos avances importantes
hemos mantenido viva la esperanza de
restringir el aumento de las
temperaturas a 1,5 grados y hemos hecho
enormes progresos en lo que respecta al
carbón los autos el dinero en efectivo y
los árboles como parte del acuerdo los
países se han comprometido a reunirse el
año que viene para acordar nuevas
reducciones a las emisiones de carbono
de modo que se pueda alcanzar el
objetivo de un calentamiento no mayor a
los 1.5 grados celsius